you lose us doofus something like that
that must be a new hand or right now not
super new but I never play them so got a
king's indian not just accepts an usual
p 6 hmm give a mysterious move maybe he
was boss's boss he sorry nope tongue
twister was he afraid of c-5 really okay
94 maybe I know he just placed this this
position Wow
okay yeah I thought gaining some space
here make some sense Bishop c4 is also
good move to get in maybe queen a force
something but I wanted to get more
controller with g4s roop t4 is
notoriously retailing move here it's the
only kind of idea that he sometimes can
have this is d foursquare other than
that he's some strategically in us in a
very dubious position a bit bit of a
shame is that I can never easily go f3s
night h5 seems rather irritating on the
dark squares yep as I said that's the
only only kind of possible counter play
that him that he might have so um let's
check it Bishop takes pawn takes rook
cheeks yeah it means that that's not
really not really working but I
understand the idea you want some kind
of play here so the easiest should be to
just play rookie form yeah let's do that
let's not make a big fuss out of that
that is some definitely better for me
and it's no reason to do anything crazy
so books you one now or group d 1 a look
see one comes with the tempo so I guess
I guess this one so
to add Teague on v6 or not he wants to
get this counter play with Bishop g4 12
I go Bishop g4 Bishop c4 vishal g4s
probably stronger
rook e8 set queen c6 well cb6 takes
Quincy 6 double attacking this is why
yes so he immediately gives up that pawn
bishop is six now there should be six
it's probably not right runs into direct
rookie aid stuff a check it's not so
easy anyway because of the opposite
Khalid bishops and some takes takes
Bishop takes
check should take Santa maybe something
like this ideas to get to the seventh
with the rook or maybe you can play look
that oh look the one can play em look at
four no okay okay so check can I go can
I do something from this position be
five yep put that down and now try to
hmm I'm not sure that this is a draw it
might be but
I thought 85 try to run with the King
and I don't know this I don't think this
is a draw it would be would be quite
weird f/4g for I can get the King to e4
then g 5 h 4f I mark I don't think said
this is a draw don't think so
I can you false actually not a great
when I can actually go h4 h4 Bishop
takes g5 king is seven takes h6 ok I
think I can do that you will stop the
edge porn with Bishop burn f6 still I
cannot believe that this is annoying g5
time morning or f5 directly f5 g5f 6
king of five back then h5 and I'm going
to g6 if I have tix that's not working
so let's do this
hmm yeah we should be 5f seven we cannot
prevent that really I think check
alright seemed bishop here king of five
and then march stuff over here yeah i'm
looking at five and push the pause check
check check check black resins yam it
was tricky I think he had a couple of
ways to I mean I was really surprised
that he took their own discern chat
because I didn't think it was entirely
necessary to do so I mean he couldn't he
can just stay but ok i really am i'm not
sure i'm really not sure i was thinking
it could be an idea when you went here
to play a five and then try to run for
that porn it's probably not working but
i have from here like this I have my own
pawns and some around here this is this
little proof too much will be an
overload for that Bishop iam so Kevin
yes to take
I really think that's losing from black
now I get childhood pawns yeah I think
it's losing I think it's not done it's
not good to take on g7 that was
interesting by the one thing that I
would like to like to see if I had a
better way even to to play against this
now the engine is actually giving f3 not
taking this pawn and that's the drew
this room yeah okay I just wanted to
play it simple and this is what i did be
takes is probably better him and now we
get this end game type of stuff i can
just take the three Oh God go walk on
how easy is it uh no rooks III a now
this is a typical case of not looking at
at the not looking properly I was just
thinking okay this or the cell attacking
e6 and of course I can just take them
and it was it was just stupid now anyway
I think at least we got a good
interesting end came out of it thanks
for watching